قبل شروق الشمس بقليل ، ضربت عدة غارات جوية
منشأة لتخزين الوقود هنا
في مدينة أوديسا ، وهي مدينة ساحلية رئيسية على
الساحل الجنوبي على طول البحر الأسود ،
وهذا هو أهم هجوم
شهدته أوديسا منذ بدء الحرب في أوكرانيا
بعد الهجوم مباشرة.  لكي
نشق طريقنا إلى مكان الحادث ، غالبًا ما
تكون منطقة صناعية في المدينة ، لكن
هناك عددًا من المباني السكنية
والمنازل على تل يطل على
منشأة تخزين الوقود ، تحدثنا مع العديد من
السكان في تلك المنطقة الذين وصفوا
اللحظات المرعبة للانفجار.
النوافذ المحطمة
يتدافع الناس للاحتماء في تلك
اللحظات الأولى مع استمرار اندلاع الحرائق والانفجارات ،
على بعد
عدة مئات من الأمتار فقط من المكان
الذي كانوا يقفون فيه ،
لحظات مرعبة للغاية هنا هذا الصباح ، ولكن
ما هو مثير للاهتمام أيضًا في
الإقامة التي تحدثنا عنها  أخبرنا ثلاثة
أشخاص مختلفين أنهم
كانوا يسمعون طائرات استطلاع بدون طيار
تحلق فوق المنطقة لعدة أيام
ورجل  كان الناس يعتقدون
أن شيئًا سيئًا على وشك الحدوث
بسبب أن المسؤولين العسكريين الروس
يقولون إنهم أطلقوا صواريخ عالية الدقة
على هذه الأهداف من
مواقع برية وبحرية كانوا يستهدفون
منشأة تخزين الوقود هذه لأنها
تزود القوات الأوكرانية بالوقود.
يقول المسؤولون العسكريون الأوكرانيون إنه
لم تكن هناك إصابات في موقع الانفجار
ولكن طوال معظم اليوم
حتى بعد ساعات وساعات من وقوع
الانفجار ، لا يزال رجال الإطفاء في ذلك المكان
يواصلون محاربة الحريق
إد لافينديرا سي إن إن أوديسا أوكرانيا ،
لذا أريد أن أبدأ بهؤلاء.
صور وتقارير مروعة من bucha
ما هو رد فعلك وهل ترى
أدلة هنا على جرائم ضد الإنسانية
أه دانا لا يمكنك إلا أن
ترى هذه الصور
كآه لكمة على القناة الهضمية وانظرنا قلنا
قبل عدوان روسيا
كنا نظن أنه من المحتمل
أنهم سيرتكبون فظائع منذ
العدوان وقلنا إننا
نعتقد أن القوات الروسية لديها  لقد ارتكبنا
جرائم حرب ونحن نعمل على
توثيق ذلك
لتوفير المعلومات التي لدينا
للمؤسسات والمنظمات ذات الصلة
التي ستجمع كل هذا معًا
ويجب أن تكون هناك مساءلة عنها ،
لكنني أعتقد أن أهم شيء هو
أننا  لا يمكننا أن نكون مخدرين في هذا الأمر ،
لا يمكننا تطبيع هذا ،
فهذه هي حقيقة ما يحدث
كل يوم طالما استمرت
وحشية روسيا ضد أوكرانيا
لهذا السبب يجب أن تنتهي
، وقال وزير الخارجية الأوكراني إن
روسيا تهدف إلى  القضاء على أكبر عدد ممكن من
الأوكرانيين بما
يتجاوز جرائم الحرب ، هل ترى أن هذا
يبدو إبادة جماعية ،
سنبحث بجدية ونوثق
كل ما نراه
معًا ،
تأكد من أن المؤسسات والمنظمات ذات الصلة
التي تبحث في
هذا
بما في ذلك وزارة الخارجية
لديهم كل ما يحتاجون إليه لتقييم
ما حدث بالضبط في أوكرانيا من
المسؤول وماذا يعني